- What do you get out of sexting?
Like, oh my god, I can't
wait to see that photo.
I'm gonna get right to it.
Like, who are you touching?
- Today we're gonna be reading scenarios
and deciding whether or not it's cheating.
- Of course, like any kind of
sexual type stuff is cheating.
Then you have, like the online
slight in the DMs type of situation.
- If you have to question
if it's cheating or nah,
then it's probably cheating.
- For me, cheating is like both physical,
like you shouldn't be kissing,
or like fucking anyone else.
- Your partner will cuddle
slash spoons with someone else.
Cheating or nah?
- I would rather have my
husband kiss someone else
than cuddle with them.
- When I spoon, it's pretty intense.
So if I were to spoon someone else,
I would say that I was cheating.
- If my wife was doing it, cool.
If I was doing it, that's not cool.
- Your partner has been
texting someone they met
and then deleting their
messages afterwards.
Cheating or nah?
- Of course.
This is all emotional cheating.
Which is equivalent to physical.
I don't see a difference.
- In a relationship where
you like sending nudes,
like hopefully you'd be
doing that to your partner,
so it's like, "Well, why aren't
you sending me the nudes?
"Why can't I get the dick pic?"
- Your partner kisses someone else.
Cheating or nah?
- Let's start with cheek.
Innocent.
- Cheek?
Kiss that cheek.
- Moves to the mouth.
- Um.
- To light peck.
- That's fine still.
- Then they actually slip some tongue.
- So I'm gonna do this thing.
- Yeah.
- Where it's nah, yeah, nah, yeah.
- That's how you get cold sores.
- Or other diseases.
- Your partner is flirting
with someone through text
but never meets them.
Cheating or nah?
- Are we swiping left
on these or right, like?
- Yeah, I feel like this
is like a Tinder situation.
Like, if that's the case,
then why does your partner
have Tinder to begin with?
- I think it's a problem
because like your partner
then is looking for some
kind of validation or some,
something through text
and it would make me
incredibly uncomfortable.
- I will just be being
myself and my friend's like,
"Oh, you were flirting so hard."
And I'm like, "Was I?"
I wasn't even aware that I was flirting.
So I feel like I could
easily be texting someone
and not know that I'm flirting
and I'd be like, "Oh,
this is just me talking."
- At the end of the day,
just talk with your partner
and make sure you're on the same page
about what cheating is and isn't.
- Cheating is like you
just bought a popsicle.
You wanna keep that ice cream to yourself.
- You physically go all
the way with someone
then yeah, you've just
violated that relationship.
Outside of that though, I
mean, if you look at somebody,
and may flirt a little bit, you good fam.
Just stay true to home.
(upbeat pop music)